if you had the organs of a serial killer
sewn into you what would you do you now
need human flesh to live and the
government kills people like you I'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat the
terrifying Monsters of Tokyo Ghoul this
kid is going to get his flesh ripped
from his bones kaneki here is your
average kid and manages to set up a date
with the finest girl in town this
purple-haired girl and kaneki takes her
out on the most amazing date and at the
end of it they pass through this empty
alley she Whispers into his ear and
tells him a naughty secret when all of a
sudden she rips through his flesh and
bites into his neck blood spills
everywhere as kaneki looks on in horror
and he can do nothing but realize that
this man eater is about to brutally
murder him okay I could tell you that
going down a dark alley was a bad idea
to begin with on a first date but how
are we supposed to know that they seem
seemingly sweet girls would literally Go
full octopus mode on us according to
statistictimes.com Japan ranks number 12
on the Global Peace Index scale behind
countries like Switzerland and Iceland
and is the only Asian country within the
top 20 lists aside from Singapore and if
we don't count countries within the
asia-pacific region like New Zealand but
even if we were in Japan just avoid dark
scary alleys in general guys come on now
now kaneki running after having his neck
ripped apart was actually quite
reasonable as during a traumatic event
his body would have likely released
adrenaline triggering his flight or
flight response and would have caused
several self-preservation responses with
one of them being increased energy and
this means that kaneki if he got the
chance could have run away and have been
relatively fine sorta even in his
condition for hours after his injuries
due to an effect known as stress-induced
analgesia which is a natural mechanism
that comes with the release of
adrenaline that can help people carry on
functioning even after after such a
traumatic event though let's be honest
there's no way we're surviving this the
best you could have done was to try and
run away and yell for help this is why
you should never just date after just
looking at a person a few times during
the week you should vet them a little
bit and if you get lonely that's what
long-distance relationships are for
kaneki tries to escape but is grabbed
and toyed around with by purple hair
girl her back busts open revealing blood
red tentacles and she tears into his
stomach right in front of him she then
grabs kaneki's soft neck and prepares to
bite him for the last time when suddenly
construction pillars fall down and Crush
purple hair girl kaneki then suddenly
wakes up in a hospital and he doesn't
know how he got here this video is
sponsored by private internet access but
oh no the government's on your ass but
you go to Google how to ask out a chick
before you ask her Toca and we're gonna
need spicy ass noodles while we do this
driving interacts with the most
transparent VPN provider and won't store
none of the weird questions you weeps
Google and I know you Google weird [ __ ]
I do too and they'll keep Japan's
government and the world out of your
business when you're not shooting your
shot at Toca like Will Chamberlain at
the free throw line you can take it easy
and watch stuff like Tokyo Ghoul ah even
in U.S with a click of a button
switching your country to wherever it's
available
but you know all this stuff what you
don't know is that these guys have a no
logs policy that's been proven in court
multiple times they don't keep your
stuff and the courts have actually
proven it this thing is more
customizable than my spicy noodle dish
your new Mad extra chilies in here it's
not spicy
what am I doing we could customize your
VPN experience to suit any and all of
yours and Minds cheeky browsing needs oh
it works with all major streaming
services blocks ads it's 100 open source
available to the public 83 countries
with next gen servers up in this [ __ ]
and you can connect up to 10 devices per
subscription use our link and you'll get
an 82 discount on private internet
access that's just two dollars and 11
cents a month you'll get three months
extra completely free
look at your crypto credit and gift
cards doctor support your boys I'm dying
here thank you to private internet
access for sponsors of video back to the
show he finds out that his organs have
been replaced by a donor the same donor
that tore into his flesh last night
purple hair girl hungry he takes a bite
out of some food but realizes it tastes
horrible he later leaves the hospital to
head home and finds out on the news that
there is a ghoul problem in Tokyo ghouls
are vampire-like creatures caused by a
virus and he finds out that the trait of
a ghoul is that they can't eat any human
food it tastes horrible to them shocked
kaneki suddenly runs to his fridge and
tries to eat everything he can get his
hands on but it all tastes horrible
causing him to vomit it all back up the
poor kid starts freaking out and he
realizes that he might just be turning
into a horrifying ghoul himself kaneki
hasn't eaten anything in almost 24 hours
and is starving he suddenly smells
something delicious and heads out side
and runs down this alley and he follows
the smell all the way to a human corpse
that's being eaten by a ghoul it offers
to share its food with him and this
horrifies kaneki but he doesn't have
time to think as another ghoul shows up
and kills the ghoul that was eating the
corpse this glasses guy thinks that
kaneki is invading his killing area and
is about to kill him until the same girl
from the cafe earlier shows up to chase
glasses guy away she introduces herself
as Toca and tells kaneki that he needs
to eat human meat to survive but kaneki
refuses to admit that he is now a ghoul
just as an old man shows up and offers
to take him in the old man takes kaneki
back to his place located right above
kaneki's favorite coffee shop he tells
kaneki that he is now part ghoul which
means he can only eat human flesh and
drink black coffee and mentions that
there is a war coming and that kaneki
will need to learn how to hunt if he
wants to survive he tells him that he'll
lose control if he doesn't feel feet and
tells him that this coffee shop is a
safe place for ghouls to visit and eat
the old man thinks that because purple
hair girl's organs are inside kaneki he
now has her powers okay at this point we
are on the clock if what the old man is
telling us is true then this means that
we don't have long before we start to
lose our minds and we already have to
some degree have experienced the side
effects from whatever this hunger is I'd
suck it up and eat whatever the old man
gives me because honestly we don't have
much other choice right now but after
that I'd begin conducting my own
experiments on myself and see how we
react under stress to our human meat
Cravings over this next month and I'd
also begin to make notes of how much
coffee is needed to suppress our
appetite and for how long this can be
achieved before starvation sets in
because we have a very big problem on
our hands if we're the first human ghoul
hybrid at least around these parts then
this means that we'll begin to draw
attention from everyone we meet
government and ghouls alike and I'm
willing to bet that unlike the old man
here there are some sick twisted sickos
out there who wouldn't mind kidnapping a
handsome happy ghoul like me to keep in
their basement and who knows what
they're into we need to get a handle on
our [ __ ] now and learn everything there
is to know about ourselves including our
abilities our weaknesses and who around
here we should and shouldn't go near the
next day kaneki goes to school and
struggles to keep it together as he gets
more and more hungry for human flesh and
meets up with his human best friend
orange hair guy and kaneki follows him
into a senior student's office to
collect some books and the two bump into
none other than glass's guy but he acts
like he's never met kaneki before and
agrees to help kaneki's best friend with
some homework at home kaneki scared for
his best friend's life offers to tag
along with the two the three then head
out and stop for food and after glasses
guide leads them under this bridge
suddenly glasses guy kicks the [ __ ] out
of orange hair guy down the street
leaving just him and kaneki all alone
okay I don't know who messed up his
breakfast but glasses guy gets pissed
off way too quick it seems though he's a
pikaku ghoul which means that he's
pretty darn good at regenerating himself
and is durable as hell our best friend
we've known since our childhood is lying
there passed out which you know what
this means folks we should ditch him
right here and now so we don't get our
asses handed to us we haven't had any
training yet we're up against a full-on
combat ready ghoul the only thing that
we have on our side sort of is the
illusion of law which means I doubt that
glasses guy would like to draw attention
to himself if he can help it our best
bet would have been to run like hell
towards the sunny-lit streak that we
just passed and blended into the sea of
people and we leave our best friend to
die this could at least guarantee our
safety while we run back to the coffee
shop the one that the old man owns and
whined him about this school not playing
nice with us because did you see glasses
guys scary ass face you gotta be
sniffing on glue if you think I'm
fighting that monster glass's guy gets
angry at kaneki for getting in the way
of his human dinner and attacks him he
takes a bite out of orange hair guy and
this pisses off kaneki he unleashes a
fury-filled raged and defeats glasses
guy badly but kaneki then realizes that
he now has to face his most horrifying
enemy his own hunger for human flesh he
looks at his best friend passed out and
is oh so tempted to peel the flesh off
of his bones when suddenly Toka shows up
to stop him she tells him that if he
wants to keep his Humanity intact he
needs to learn to resist the urge to
attack his friends and mentions that no
one can know about his ghoul identity
ever but kaneki is too hungry to listen
and forces Hoka to knock him out later
kaneki wakes up back at the coffee shop
and realizes that the old man already
fed him the one thing he refused to eat
for so long human flesh and this freaks
out kaneki but the old man then offers
him a job to work at this coffee shop
and tells him that he'll be able to
train here and learn to live life as a
ghoul saying that with some practice
he'll soon be able to go back to his
human life very soon right kaneki begins
training and sees humans and undercover
ghouls visit the coffee shop daily but
then on the news they suddenly get word
of a series of murders that have begun
to take place in the 20th Ward Toca
hears this and gets concerned for what's
to come she then tells kaneki that if he
is to survive he must avoid the hunters
known as box carriers which are police
specially trained in killing and hunting
down ghouls okay if I was kaneki at this
point I'd study the old man and find out
everything I could about my situation I
wouldn't just rely on what he tells me I
would also become best friends with the
workers of this place and find out what
they know about this place and how it
works because it's unlikely I'll get the
full picture of my situation from just
relying on one source of information he
may be the one who runs things around
here but I bet he doesn't have all the
answers this also leads me to wonder if
this coffee shop is a refuge for ghouls
why don't they have more like these
around Tokyo's Wards if I was kaneki I'd
talk to the old man about the
possibility a franchising this
establishment by opening up more coffee
shops like this all around Tokyo this
could benefit us tenfold and would help
me if on the off chance I have to leave
the 20th Ward for whatever reason this
would give me a nice schools like me
places to stay we can't just sit around
and be complacent and most importantly I
gotta cover my butt in case the cops
come for me and find me in the 20th Ward
in another part of town at the police
headquarters this guy mentions that they
found a wrench made of Queen case steel
at a recent murder in the 20th Ward and
thinks that this wrench would lead them
to the faction behind all the deaths
happening there this is the same ward
where kaneki was turned into a ghoul and
the police think that the ghouls there
are up to something horrifying but they
don't have much time to get to the
bottom of this as the police chief
mentioned that the 11th ward of Tokyo is
turning into a war zone between humans
and ghouls fearing that if they don't
solve all of this soon a terrifying war
will break out between the species all
over Tokyo they then send off two of
their top dog detectives Mr stud over
here and Mr creepy face and they go
investigate the wrench and the murders
down in the 20th Ward later at the ghoul
Cafe Old Man shows kaneki how to pretend
to eat like a human and orders Toka to
help kaneki get a ghoul mask but he
suddenly mentions that he can sense that
two terrifying ghoul Hunters have just
entered the 20th Ward he then tells
these two to step on the gas and Toka
and kaneki rush off to get him suited up
with a mask and then they tug about a
bunch of useless anime Exposition on the
way there and back the next day a
strange man named purple hair guy walks
into the cafe and suddenly takes a
eerily huge amount of interest in kaneki
but Toca warns kaneki to stay away from
him but somehow this guy's charm is too
much for kaneki to handle and this guy
chats kaneki up and down and later even
follows him to school and demands that
the two have coffee at his castle
tomorrow night and like the gullible
little munchkin that he is kaneki agrees
the next day kaneki begins training with
white haired guy and hits up a bar
afterwards there they meet red-haired
girl who take takes an interest in
kaneki he asks her about the identity of
his organ donor purple hair girl but she
tells him the only thing anyone knows
about her is that she came from the 11th
ward the same ward that is now turned
into a war zone but red-haired girl
thinks that purple hair girl's death was
no accident that someone brutally
murdered her but of course she has no
proof and makes kaneki suspicious as
hell later kaneki shows up for dinner at
purple hair guy's Castle not knowing
what Horrors await him he's greeted with
a coffee but then is suddenly dumped
right into a terrifying Death Match
Arena and this huge Man shows up ready
to fight kaneki and brutally tear him
apart the crowd cheers on as they wait
to eat the losing opponent this was
purple hair guy's Clan all along kaneki
tries to escape with his life but he
gets tossed around more than a chef with
his salad bowl and he freaks the hell
out knowing that he's about to die Holy
balls do we have a problem this big baby
has some big problems by the looks of
things isn't a afraid to toss us around
for fun but what strikes me about him
and which could possibly be a weakness
of his is his intellect based on his
interaction with that other ghoul who he
calls Mama it makes me think that this
ghoul not only has a surprisingly low
intellect but also relies on people to
give him orders like a baby listening to
a parent if we could influence his mind
to deter him from attacking us much like
establishing Authority towards a child
I'm wondering if we could stop him from
attacking us or even make him hand over
his weapon to us through parenting
techniques designed to work on making
children abide by rules after all
children are much more susceptible to
suggestions from authority figures so if
we utilize parenting techniques and
negotiation tactics designed to
illustrate our perceived power we may be
able to gain control over big baby if
that doesn't work all we have to do is
to stay outside of the range of his
attacks and let him Tire himself out
until he gets exhausted big baby is much
bigger than us and will tire out much
faster and also because he's so much
bigger than us means that he's going to
get hotter much faster and will sweat a
whole lot causing the floor to get wet
and increase the odds of him slipping
and possibly breaking an ankle which
would increase our odds of survival
kaneki knows he's about to be brutally
murdered when suddenly his one eye turns
into the eye of a horrifying ghoul this
stuns the crowd as they realize just how
rare of a species kaneki truly is purple
hair guy in the distance sees this and
gets a terrifying idea he suddenly stops
the game and tells kaneki that this was
all one big joke and lets kaneki go free
for now the next morning kaneki finds
out that Toca has gotten sick from
eating too much of her human friend's
food but she doesn't realize that her
niceness will cost her tonight kaneki
then heads out into town and runs into
glasses guy getting beat up he saves him
and dumps him off at his apartment where
he meets his girlfriend and she's human
this girl says that glasses guy needs
human flesh to heal but having none
there kaneki runs back to the coffee
shop to get some and that was his
biggest mistake he reached his door when
he sees a cart just outside his window
with a rose it's an invite from purple
hair guy to join him again at church but
this time he has glasses guy's
girlfriend suddenly like clockwork
glasses guy shows up barely clinging to
life he says that his girlfriend has
been taken the two ghouls go out to save
glasses guy's girlfriend before it's too
late okay this is nuts kidnapping us is
one thing but now it's official
purple-haired guy is certifiably insane
which makes him only more dangerous
we've seen how purple hair guy operates
and how much of a Sharp tongue this guy
has he's a smooth talker and this is
exactly why I would have waited and
asked more ghouls for help such as
asking the old man and white-haired guy
for their assistance from the letter
it's not clear what we're up against but
purple haired guy recently did try to
eat me so I think it's fair to say that
nothing good is about to happen and also
by basically going alone kaneki failed
to ensure that his group's strength
between him and glasses guy was Secure
glasses guy is already injured and you
already know kaneke barely knows how to
do anything the only fights they're
going to have for them is their trust
between them as teammates which is
already in Jeopardy by purple hair guys
Charisma hear me out now charismatic
individuals often do well in positions
of power but these attributes can run
the risk of sabotaging relationships and
eroding trust between people and groups
the problem is is that purple-haired guy
is smart and already in a position of
power and he's holding all of the cards
kaneki going alone with glasses guy
means that purple-haired guy threw his
Charisma and positional power could
convince glasses guy to turn against us
after all purple hair guy does have
glasses guy's girlfriend which means
there's nothing to stop him from
ordering glasses guy to follow his
orders and we know glasses guy will do
anything to save his girlfriend kaneki
should have gotten help from people with
no invested interest in the situation
such as the old man wide-haired guy or
possibly even Toca at the church the
boys find glasses guy's girlfriend
horribly bound and binded by ropes and
She lays on top of a table ready to be
eaten like a holiday ham purple hair guy
is a total foodie and demands that
kaneki Feast on glass's guy's girlfriend
as purple hair guy feasts on kaneki but
that's when kaneki sees the scars on
this girl he realizes that glasses guy
has been feeding on his girlfriend
kaneki then gets angry and he and Toca
attacked purple hair guy but they both
realized that none of them have it in
flesh in a while and are no match for
this bad guy so kaneki lets Toca take a
bite out of his body and they then badly
injure purple hair guy good okay Toca
showing up was a welcome surprise but
she played it risky she shouldn't have
been eating any human food at all even
from her friends and this almost got
herself killed in the process this is
why you should never try to be too good
of a friend always settle for mediocrity
people now the good news is that
purple-haired guy wanted kaneki as part
of his plan and likely wouldn't have
minded waiting a little bit longer
before harming glasses guy's girlfriend
so long as he thought that kaneki would
take part in his plan this is why I'm
suggesting bringing more people to take
on purple hair guy as it's obvious he's
a strong ghoul and is likely capable of
taking on a lot of damage regular old
ghouls can take serious damage with a
strong injury to the stomach or by
decapitation to the head and are also a
little bit stronger depending on if they
just ate but I'm kissing our
purple-haired foodie over here is always
feasting on flesh which means his
kagunae and powers are likely at their
strongest or near their strongest I
would have utilized Toca and a third
party by making them hide outside the
church and lure a purple-haired guy out
towards there with kaneki then after I
would have tried going for his head
while glasses guy sneaks in the back of
the church to rescue his girlfriend then
combating purple haired guy if
decapitation didn't work I would have
tried enabling him to use up all of his
powers on me in succession as that is a
method to weaken ghouls is to have them
use up their power cells through
constant attacks or deployed kagunas and
with enough time in the ring I think we
could have weakened purple-haired guy
enough to either critically wound him or
Scare him off entirely purple hair guy
is on the brink of death and that's when
Toca calms down and she realizes that
glass's guy's girlfriend knows the idea
identity of ghouls therefore she has to
die glasses guy desperately begs for his
girlfriend's life but Toca doesn't
listen she prepares to end this girl's
life but suddenly the girlfriend
comments on how beautiful Toco looks
which saddens this ghoul and took a
Caves at the last minute sparing This
Girl's Life and she runs away Days Later
glasses guy ends up working at the ghoul
coffee shop and everything seems to be
hunky-dory but none of these people
realize that their life is about to
change for the worst suddenly this ghoul
mother walks into the cafe not realizing
that she's about to die in less than an
hour kaneki notices this concerned
customer and checks in with her and she
tells kaneki about her family drama her
husband is in some debt with some bad
guys and he's been trying to pay it off
her husband is a blacksmith and he is
used by bad ghouls to make weapons and
tools for them we see him hard at work
at his office as this guy shows up
called white suit man this man tells the
husband that the police are looking for
the wrench that he made in connection
with a recent murder in the 20th Ward
and that he better keep his mouth shut
if he wants to live and throws him
outside the window to punish him and
that's when his worst nightmare shows up
it's the Box carriers Mr stud and creepy
face white suit man escapes just as
these police tell the husband that they
think he's behind the murders in the
20th War since they know he made the
wrench the husband tries to fight back
like an idiot and get slaughtered and he
falls to the floor holding a drawing
that his daughter made for him and
unfortunately for him he doesn't realize
that this exact drawing will cost him
the life of his wife in less than an
hour okay pops over here was one stupid
fellow to try and go up against a
professionally trained ghoul
investigator these guys are the best of
the best and know how to handle ghouls
without much problem and also like I
said about kaneki if I was a ghoul I'd
study religiously everything there is to
know about the CCP police and I'd
especially study the ways and methods
and abilities and tactics of my kind's
worst enemy the ghoul investigator
himself and whoever their top the
members are this way we could have at
least known better as to what we were up
against creepy face over here is the
best of the best and the most ruthless
of them all and his handling of his
weapons means that pops was no match for
him in this case we had little choice
but to run and hopefully take refuge
somewhere safer before figuring out our
next step or we could have run just far
enough before taking a human hostage and
use them as a distraction before
escaping likely we couldn't have done
much but fighting was definitely not the
first option I would have gone with
after everybody gets all caffeinated up
at the ghoul Cafe the mother and
daughter head back home but that's when
the daughter realizes that something is
not right she smells something and
follows the scent down the street it's
her dad sent and the two followed down
this alley and that's when a wave of
dread hits the mother's face she sees Mr
stud and creepy face standing across
from them holding the body parts of This
Woman's husband the mother quickly
unleashes her full ghoul powers and she
tells her daughter one simple word run
and she Sprints away and runs into
kaneki and he is forced to hold back
this little girl's pain and and Trauma
as they're both forced to watch this
mother get brutally murdered right here
and now later the ghoul gang Mourns the
death of the mother and Toca gets so mad
that she leaves the cafe she's
determined to slaughter the police and
make them pay and she heads to a ramen
shop nearby that's beloved by the police
there she sees Mr stud and some of his
co-workers and she brutally murders this
policeman and tries to take Mr stud on
herself he tries to defend himself but
that's when Mr creepy face shows up and
he knows everything about ghouls Toca
tries to kill this guy but he's too good
for her own good and forces her to run
away but her ghoul bunny mask is one
thing Mr creepy face can't get out of
his mind and now he'll come for her very
soon okay I would love to talk to Toka
right now and ask her why are you so
dang distracted and in your own head did
you fail to be in the present and act in
a more calculated manner going in
unprepared an attacking head-on is a bad
idea she was outmatched in both numbers
and physical strength Toca should have
realized her strength better and play to
them rather than out of emotion toga
herself is a type of ghoul that
specializes in high speed attacks which
means that her enhanced speed and
Mobility is her main bread and butter
and not brute strength if I was there in
helping Toca because I do like the idea
of killing ghoul investigators I would
suggest we go to their home of residence
and kill them when they're at their most
vulnerable Toko could have followed the
investigators back to their separate
homes and killed them one by one over
the course of a few nights granted each
night that passes would have gotten
progressively harder as the news of a
cop killer would no doubt put everyone
more on edge however she also could have
avoided this by concentrating her
efforts on the main ghoul investigator
that actually killed the girl's mom
creepy face Revenge doesn't solve
anything unless you do it right the days
pass as this girl Mourns the death of
her parents she finally decides to get
away from the ghoul Cafe to get some air
and then she smells something it's the
scent of her mother she runs like mad to
track down her mother's scent and heads
down into this Sinister tunnel but
suddenly creepy face up squeals and
screams Echo throughout the streets
until kaneki hears her he desperately
runs to find her but then runs into Mr
stutt and kaneki is pissed as hell and
turns into a full Monster and manages to
destroy Mr stud's Queen but this ghoul
killer isn't No Cry Baby and tells
kaneki to finish the damn job and kill
him but kaneki hasn't eaten in forever
and he begs Mr stud to run for his life
before he becomes kaneki's lunch finally
Mr stud listens to kaneki and runs off
and kaneki goes to find the little girl
back under the bridge Toca finally
reaches the little girl screams and
attacks creepy face until he reveals
something horrifying creepy Face's
weapon is made from the Flesh of this
little girl's mother terrifying this
girl and this finally makes Toca lose it
she beats the [ __ ] out of creepy face
and chops off his hand leaving him on
the brink of death and then kaneki and
white-haired guy show up to take the
little girl and Toca away okay this
could have been easily avoided if they
just knew how to contain the little brat
they should not have put someone there
to just watch her they should also
installed some sort of a tracker on her
it's obvious that after her mother's
death the little girl would have likely
been altered psychologically at least to
some degree this is common with
individuals who experience severe trauma
like witnessing the death of a loved one
and this can cause temporary or even
permanent personality alteration and
lead to a dramatic shift in behavior
from General temperament to General
stress tolerance and even an altered
outlook on life we don't know how much
this affected this little girl but it's
safe to say that at this current period
of time the little girl is a liability
and a problem if she handles this poorly
and the old man should have had better
security measures during this period of
time also being such a feared member of
the ghoul investigators it wouldn't be
improbable to say that Toca along with
the rest of the ghouls could have
figured out a way in advance the
limitation of creepy faces Queen K as
creepy face has a habit of collecting
Queen K's and is sense his tend to be
made from the past ghouls he's killed
they could have used this information to
figure out creepy faces weak points when
using each of his selected weapons again
this should have been done way in
advance Toco would have had much better
luck in changing her tactics from
offensive to defensive creepy Face's
second Queen K was made from the little
girl's mother's kagun and hers is a type
of Queen K that is extremely durable and
can function as both offense and defense
however this guy's weapon because of its
ginormous size means that they would
have had a hard time being as Mobile in
tight areas and Toca could have used
this to her Advantage the next day
kaneki goes to redhead girl's bar to
find out more information about purple
hair girl and finds out that she came
from the 11th ward of Tokyo redhead
tells kaneki that he'll probably get
some answers on her if he goes to the
11th ward himself but she warns him that
he needs to go soon as police forces
will soon arrive there to cause some
trouble nearby a group of horrifying
ghouls show up to the 20th Ward and they
prepare for their mission to find purple
hair girl before anyone else does
starting at her favorite coffee shop the
one kaneki works at later at Police
Headquarters Mr studies given a new band
of assistance as everyone prepares for
their a horrifying mission to invade the
11th ward and they suddenly get a call
from the 11th ward itself they find out
that terrifying ghouls have taken over
all the police stations there killing
every single cop they could find and
they watch everyone on the screen get
brutally killed back at the coffee shop
a ghoul named Mr goatee shows up with
his henchmen and asks about the location
of purple hair girl but he suddenly
catches her scent on kaneki and demands
he tells him where she is but kaneki
then knocks this guy to the floor but
kaneki doesn't want to hurt this guy's
feelings so he lies and tells Mr goatee
that purple hair girl left the cafe
earlier today Mr goatee thinks purple
hair girl is alive and cheers up and he
then throws kaneki a bone and tells him
that trouble is looking for him as they
speak some more ghouls aside from Mr
goatee have recently invaded the 20th
Ward looking for purple hair girl too
but these ghouls are crazy as hell and
just like the 11th ward plan to turn
this place into a war zone 2. Mr goatee
thanks kaneki for his time and his Squad
heads out suddenly Mr goatee comes
flying back in through the shop window
glass at insteps the Psycho Mob Boss
from before Mr white suit he takes an
immediate interest in kaneki and asks
him for purple hair girl's location but
kaneki doesn't tell him [ __ ] so he beats
the crap out of him as everybody nearby
looks around helpless these guys are
true killers and have horrifying plans
for kaneki Toka tries to stop this Thug
from kidnapping him but purple hair kit
brutally beats her before they leave and
also reveals to everyone that he's her
long-lost brother yay family reunited
later the old man and white-haired guy
come back to the now utterly destroyed
coffee shop and find out that kaneki has
been kidnapped but the old man is one
stubborn bastard and gathers the rest of
his crew to go save kaneki calling
everyone he knows like redhead girl and
even purple hair guy and he knows that
so many lives are going to die okay okay
okay while I admire the strong ties old
man has to his people realistically
there's little chance in hell that will
be able to save kaneki without the
losing a lot of our people in the
process we're about to storm the 11th
ward imagine the apartment building from
the movie Dread that's how bad it is
over there there's a reason why
thousands of people have died so far in
the 11th ward wow admirable this plan is
completely stupid even if you bring the
silver tongued weirdo purple hair guy
we're going up against an army and we
have less than two Bakers dozens worth
of ghouls on our side for good measure I
would have at least try to hire other
ghouls for insurance to help us in our
upcoming battle we may not get their
loyalty but at least they'll make for a
better distraction if we bring more
bodies to this upcoming bloodbath if
anything we could have used more hard
ghouls as a distraction tactic using
them and the cops who we know are headed
there to keep the majority of the 11th
ward busy while we look for kaneki
kaneki wakes up and realizes that he's
in the horrifying 11th ward and white
suit man begins to interrogate kaneki in
the most terrifyingly delicious ways
possible like removing each of this
Rule's fingers and toes again and again
as they do regenerate this quickly
drives kaneki insane and he finally
loses his [ __ ] and breaks free and
savagely kills Mr suit guy as his hair
turns a soulless white turning him into
a full-on powerful ghoul and this now
monster consumes this guy meanwhile just
outside the old man and his gang prepare
to invade the 11th ward along with
thousands of police nearby the police
storm in and hundreds of ghouls and
police die instantly it's a horrifying
battle and blood is spilled everywhere
but something is not right as everyone
here realizes it they soon hear the
rumbling of something terrifying in the
distance this police General's face goes
pale as he sees what everyone else does
the most powerful evil ghoul in the
history of mankind the old man can sense
what Horrors are about to happen and
this guy tells his task force that
anyone who doesn't want to die should
leave now and just this small group
readies their weapons and prepare to
fight the bloodiest battle against the
most powerful bad guy in the world the
one-eyed owl but what do you guys think
about Tokyo cool man that was so much
fun to make don't forget to subscribe
leave a thumbs up comment down below let
us know what you like about the video
and what you don't like about the video
and thank you private internet access
for sponsoring this video